news daily from science mission
scientists found mutations in the
essential fatty acid transport protein
in the brain these mutations caused
decreased transport of essential fatty
acids to the brain and their increase in
the plasma resulting in poor brain
development with large size ventricles
and smaller brain next soluble guanylate
cyclase produce the second messenger
called cyclic GMP and researchers show
that a small molecule stimulator of this
guanylate cyclase called bay protects
against diet-induced weight gain it
induces weight loss in established
obesity models improves diabetic
phenotype through increases in lipid
uptake and increases whole body energy
expenditure next beclan is the key
component of cellular destruction
machinery called autophagosomes that are
targeted to lysosomes for destruction
and alteration in this process may lead
to tumor growth what're show that bit
lean phosphorylation needs to its Estill
ation by a protein called p300 resulting
in blockages autophagosome maturation
and increase in tumor growth for more
news visitors at www science mission
calm or science mission facebook page
thanks for watching